[Music]
hey what's up its Alicia Malone welcome
to another Fandango indie movie guide
the show where I get to geek out about
indie movies before I get into my
recommendations I wanted to mention to
you that Detroit directed by Kathryn
Bigelow has now expanded to more
theaters so from this Friday you'll get
to see it in a whole lot more cinemas
all around the country this is her look
at the true story behind the 1967
Detroit riots looks at racism it looks
at violence and it's all done through
her lens the same lens that she uses to
look at war she looked at war on the
streets but I wanted to tell you about
some even smaller films that need to be
discovered let's start with Columbus
this is directed by Koch NIDA and it is
quite rare that you see a film these
days that you think that guy is and
ought to saw you at the hospital you
from here yeah you like it here I'm
really interested in architecture here
this town is quite the mecca coconut ax
is a video essayist whose work has been
seen on places like The Criterion
Collection he especially loves Japanese
masters like Kurosawa and OHS ooh and
the latter OHS ooh was definitely well
known for keeping a very still camera
and here you can definitely see that
influenced every single frame of
Columbus has been perfectly designed and
it really shows the relationship between
people and architecture I want to show
you something
this was one of the first modernist
banks in America who are you
I shut up I'm just trying to tell you
about this building this movie is
stylish but it's not just about
cinematography it's also about the
performances once again John show shows
just how brilliant and underrated an
actor he is and Haley Lou Richardson
will make you stop and say who is that
girl of course we saw her in split and
edge of seventeen but this really really
proves that she's said to be a big star
I think she's bright
you of all people should be in college I
just think I should stay here
do not miss Columbus very sweet and
totally affecting I loved it
next up a great documentary called step
by amanda lipid this follows a group of
dancers from Baltimore who do step
dancing but more than that it really
follows their path to their true dreams
and whether or not these girls can get
to go to college I want them to
understand that this is way bigger than
standing it's about not making excuses
making sacrifices having a positive
attitude because they can make it
through step practice so they can make
it through life blessing Corey and
Taylor are the three girls that the
documentary focuses on and they all come
from different backgrounds they're all
got their own struggles but they're all
trying to make it and it's just so
inspiring there are moments that'll
definitely make you cry are these
Reacher this why does the step team get
your best and I don't enjoy school is
what got me out of Brooklyn College is
what's gonna get you out of Baltimore
and it just feels completely empowering
particularly for women and women getting
together there is one quote which really
really stuck with me and I think it's
completely true if you come together
with a group of powerful women the
impact will be immense we stand here
today on the precipice of the future
try and say step if it's playing near
you it's out this weekend stop his life
and last but definitely not least a film
that I hope people will see even just to
see the stars who are very very famous
it's called Wind River my families
people were forced here stuck here first
entry
that's no one silence it's the only
thing that hasn't been taken from you I
need emergency assistance the Wind River
Indian Reservation you might know the
name Taylor Sheridan particularly if you
watch Sons of Anarchy because he was an
actor in that series but he was also the
screenwriter behind Sicario and hello hi
water Wind River is the film that he is
written and directed and it is a very
very impressive directorial effort this
is a homicide it's kind of like a West
End crime film it's set in the snow so
instead of the hot desert it's the
isolated cold walls don't kill unlucky
deer to tell the weak ones
you don't think I can't make it out here
you cannot blink I was not different the
movie will not only keep you on the edge
of your seat with solving this murder
and doing the procedural crime dramas so
so well but it also explores a community
of people that I don't think we see
often enough in film American Indians
and has a very interesting layer of
gender dynamics
I cannot wait to see Wind River once
again it is out in theaters this weekend
so try and track it down if you can hear
you survive you surrender so as well as
checking out Detroit there are three
fantastic indie films that you should
definitely try and see or at least note
down for when it comes to your city
Columbus is so beautiful step is a
fascinating documentary and Wind River
will keep you on the edge of your seat
do any of those films take your fancy
let me know in the comments below or you
can tweet me at Alicia Malone I'll see
you soon
[Music]
you